البرلمان التركي يعرف باسم مجلس الامه
الكبير
ينتخب الشعب المجلس الوطني مره كل خمس
سنوات
بعد التعديلات الدستوريه زاد عدد وبمن 500
الى 600
كان البرلمان سابقا يختار الرئيس والحكومه
بالاغلبيه له حق حجب الثقه بعد اعتماد
النظام الرئاسي الرئيس هو من يشكل الحكومه
لم يعد للبرلمان دور بمنحها الثقه او
المحاسبه من صلاحيات البرلمان ادخال
التعديلات على الدستور بموافقه ثلثي
اعضائه لعرض التعديلات على استفتاء شعبي
بموافقه الثلثي اعضائه يتخذ قرار اجراء
انتخابات برلمانيه ورئاسيه فيما يعد حجب
ثقه عن الرئيس وحكومته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه الوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات